bonjour à tous ce flash spécial pour
vous annoncer c'est très spectaculaire
explosion se serait un attentat selon
les médias américains l'horreur en plein
coeur de new york le 11 septembre 2001
il ya vingt ans à 8h46 heure locale la
tour nord du world trade center est
percuté par un boeing 767 d'american
airlines détourné par des terroristes
islamistes
nous avons entendu une grosse explosion
tout est soudain devenu très sombre il y
avait des débris de verre qui tombait de
partout à nantes les gens étaient
blessés c'était une grosse explosion
tout était noir scènes de chaos dans les
rues de manhattan les secours
s'organisent mais à 9h03 17 minutes
après le premier crash c'est là tout
sucre qui est la cible des pirates de
l'air et c'est en direct à la télé nous
avons posé l'avion dans l'autre tour est
très la fumée a tout envahi j'ai vu des
gens sauter par la fenêtre pour sauver
leur vie
après le world trade center le pentagone
le qg du département de la défense
américaine l'un des bâtiments les plus
surveillés et protégé des états unis à
9h37 le vol 77 d'american airlines avec
58 passagers à bord s'écrase sur le
complexe militaire à plus de 850 km
heure ces images sont celles du
pentagone donc nous ne sommes plus à new
york nous sommes à washington et c'est
le pentagone c'est à dire le siège le
ministère de la défense le siège des
armées américaines qui est en fait
autrement dit il y as bienvenus une
nouvelle explosion le pentagone et
évacuer la maison blanche aussi à plus
de 300 kilomètres de là les 9 heures 59
à new york la journée bascule un peu
plus dans l'horreur kerry a démarré en
je crois qu'à new york une des tours
s'est effondré en tout cas un bâtiment
sans doute l'une des tours n'a du mal à
distinguer pour l'instant il ya beaucoup
de fumée le plan s'élargit on va
peut-être y comprendre ce qui se passe
une des tours du world trade center
s'est effondré après la tour sud la tour
nord à 10h28
elle s'écroule à son tour dans un
panache de fumée toujours en direct à la
télé sur les images que nous voyons
alors on voit que la deuxième tours du
world trade center est en train
d'imploser s est effondré sur elle-même
elle est en train à son tour comme
l'avait fait l'autre tour un peu plus
tôt à s'est écroulé
un quatrième avion suicide n'a pas
atteint sa destination washington le vol
united airlines 93 s'est écrasé en
pennsylvanie
suite à la révolte des passagers parmi
eux mark bingham qui a réussi à joindre
s'attendent quelques minutes avant la
catastrophe
il nous a dit je vous aime beaucoup et
je ne vous reverrai probablement jamais
car l'avion ont été pris d'assaut par
des pirates de l'air
ensuite nous lui avons dit à notre tour
que nous l'aimions très fort les
attentats ont été très vite revendiqué
par al qaïda et son commanditaire
oussama ben laden bilan près de 3000
morts et plus de 6000 blessés ce sont
les attentats les plus meurtriers de
l'histoire
[Musique]